FRIENDS, AUDIENCE, AND ARE GREAT
SPONSORS.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
DISTURBING VIDEO SHOWS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
MOCKING PARENTS AS JUST WANTING
THEIR BABYSITTERS BACK.
AN OUTRAGED MOTHER IS HERE.
ALSO, WHO IS POPULATING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
NUMBER THREE AT THE DOJ.
AND AFTER THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
JOE BIDEN IS NOW FULLY ENDORSING
A STUDY LOOKING AT REPARATIONS,
THE LEGENDARY BOB FLOYD REACTS
TO THAT.
FIRST, THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT
YOU.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IN MAY 2019, THAT SHOWED TRAVEL
TO THE BORDER TOWN OF DEL RIO,
TEXAS, TO DOCUMENT THE GROWING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION CRISIS AT
THE TIME.
NO RECORD NUMBERS OF ILLEGALS,
FAMILY UNITS, AND UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS WERE FLOODING ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE.
SOON AFTERWARDS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TIGHTENED PROCESSING OF A SIDE
LEAVES AND REFUGEE APPLICATIONS
AND HE EVEN STRUCK HISTORIC
AGREEMENTS WITH MEXICO AND
CENTRAL AMERICA TO TRY TO TACKLE
THE PROBLEM HERE.
AT THE NUMBER OF BORDER CROSSERS
IN TURN DROPPED DRAMATICALLY.
BUT NOW, JOE BIDEN IS IN THE
PROCESS OF REVERSING ALL OF THAT
PROGRESS.
BEYOND CREATING A HUMANITARIAN
NIGHTMARE, HIS POLICIES WILL
CREATE MORE ECONOMIC AND
SECURITY PROBLEMS FOR AN AMERICA
THAT IS ALREADY ON THE EDGE.
SIMPLY PUT, BIDEN IS CAPTIVE TO
TWO CONSTITUENCIES.
THE LEFT, THAT WANTS TO REMAKE
OUR COUNTRY WITH NEW MORE
PROGRESSIVE VOTERS.
AND THE DONOR CLASS, THAT ONCE
AN ENDLESS SUPPLY OF CHEAP
LABOR.
HARDWORKING AMERICANS BE.
IT LISTEN TO THE PLEAS OF THE
MAYOR OF DEL RIO.
THIS IS NOT A VIDEO YOU WILL SEE
ON ANY OTHER NETWORK.
>> MR. PRESIDENT I AM PLEADING
DEAD REQUESTING TO PLEASE PUT A
HALT TO ANY MEASURES REGARDING
THE LEASE OF IMMIGRANTS A AWAITI
COURT DATES.
IF YOU DO SEND THESE INDIVIDUALS
INTO OUR COMMUNITY, WE WILL BE
FORCED TO MAKE A DECISION TO
LEAVE THEM WITHOUT RESOURCES
UNDER THESE DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE MAY BE A SMALL TOWN THAT IS
OFF OF YOUR RADAR, BUT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO 50,000 PEOPLE WHO
NEED YOUR ATTENTION.
WE ARE REQUESTING THAT YOU
PLEASE LISTEN AND THAT YOU
PLEASE COME THROUGH.
>> Laura: THERE SOMETHING THAT
I EVERY AMERICAN WATCHING RIGHT
NOW HAS TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU ARE NOT A PRIORITY FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OR
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS.
YOUR SAFETY, YOUR JOB PROSPECTS,
YOUR KIDS GOING BACK TO SCHOOL,
YOUR MENTAL HEALTH, YOUR
FREEDOM.
NONE OF THAT IS AS IMPORTANT TO
THE LEFT AS THEIR DESIRE TO
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM AMERICA.
AND ACHIEVING THIS REQUIRES THAT
THEY PASS AN AMNESTY BILL AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE, CERTAINLY
BEFORE THE NEXT ELECTION.
>>IT YOU KIND OF NEED TO BE
REPLACED BY NEW VOTERS WHO WILL
BE MORE COMPLIANT WHEN NEW
RESTRICTIONS ARE ACTIVE.
THEY NEED NEW VOTERS WHO WON’T
OBSESS ABOUT PROTECTING SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS OR WORRY ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTION AT ALL.
WE ARE JUST LEARNING NOW THE
DETAILS OF THE DEMOCRATS KNEW
AMNESTY BILL SUPPORTED BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN OF COURSE THAT
WOULD GRANT CITIZENSHIP TO AN
UNTOLD NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN THE U.S.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
THIS LEGISLATION CREATES AN
EIGHT YEAR PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
IT IMMEDIATELY GRANTS GREEN
CARDS TO FARMWORKERS, TBS
DESIGNEES, AND.GOV RECIPIENTS.
ED EXPANDS THE WORK VISA LOTTERY
FROM 50,000 TO 80,000 A YEAR.
AND IT EXEMPTS CHILDREN AND
SPOUSES FROM ANY VISA CAP
NUMBER.
IT GIVES DEPENDENCE GREEN CARDS,
IT RECAPTURES ON THE VISAS -- I
LOVE THIS ONE -- FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS TO CLEAR BACKLOG AND
ELIMINATES COUNTRY VISA CAPS AND
TAKES THE WORD "ALIEN" OUT OF
THE QUOTE.
CREATING REFUGEE PROCESSING
CENTERS AND CENTRAL AMERICA.
WELL, IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE IF
YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
BASICALLY, BIDEN IS GOING TO
CEASE DEPORTING ALL BUT THE MOST
VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
AND BORDER PATROL OFFICERS WILL
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO BAN ENTRY
AT OUR BORDERS BY THOSE WHO HAD
ALREADY BEEN HERE ILLEGALLY ON
PREVIOUS OCCASIONS.
OH, GOODY.
MOST AMERICANS AREN’T TRAVELING
OUT OF THE COUNTRY DUE TO COVID
STUFF, ILLEGALS WILL BE FREE TO
COME AND GO, NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
THIS LEGISLATION IS SPONSORED BY
PRO-OPEN BORDER SENATOR WHO WILL
CALL YOU A RACIST IF YOU DON’T
SUPPORT HIS EFFORTS.
>> TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE HAVE
COMPROMISED TOO MUCH AND FRENCH
VOICES WHO REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
HUMANITY TO OUR COUNTRY --
FROM JOHN BOEHNER TO WHITE
NATIONALISTS TO MANIPULATIVE
MADMAN NAMED DONALD TRUMP THAT
WILL ALWAYS BE THOSE WHO STAND
AGAINST IMMIGRANTS.
>> Laura: DO YOU UNDERSTAND
NOW?
FIRST OF ALL, COMPLETELY BLURS
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN ILLEGAL
AND LEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HE’S
SAYING.
BELIEF IN STRONG BORDER
ENFORCEMENT, BELIEF IN THE RULE
OF LAW, BELIEF THAT AMERICANS,
NOT A LEGAL IMMIGRANTS, SHOULD
BE THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF
OUR GOVERNMENT DEAD YOU ARE NO
DIFFERENT FROM A KKK GRAND
WIZARD.
ANYTHING TO AVOID THAT TOP ISSUE
FOR MOST AMERICANS.
OPENING SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE WHEN PELOSI IS PRESSED
ON THAT ISSUE, SHE IS HER USUAL
RAMBLING MASS.
>> THE POINT TO MAKE ON THIS IS
WHERE THERE IS A HIGH INCIDENT
OF COVID, MOST OF THOSE SCHOOLS
ARE VIRTUAL OR HYBRID ANYWAY.
AND THE VACCINATION MIGHT NOT
MAKE IT ACTUAL ANYWAY.
THERE HAS TO BE A JUDGMENT MADE
FROM THE COMMUNITY AS TO HOW
THEY GO FORWARD.
>> Laura: IS SHE TRYING TO
CONJURE UP THE ANSWER WITH THE
HAND MOTIONS?
I’LL GIVE YOU A TRANSLATION OF
WHAT OLD NANCY SAID.
SINCE ROUGHLY 89% OF STUDENTS
LIVE IN COVID RED ZONES, SCHOOLS
ARE OUT OF SESSION FOR IN-PERSON
LEARNING AS FAR AS I CAN TELL,
FOREVER.
AND SPEAKING OF RED ZONE SCUM OF
THE CITIES HIT HARDEST BY COVID,
THREE OF THE TOP FOUR ARE BORDER
TOWNS.
JUST A TOTAL COINCIDENCE I’M
SURE.
AT A TIME OF MASS UNEMPLOYMENT
WITH MILLIONS OF AMERICAN KIDS
STUCK IN ZOOM HELL, WHY WOULD
THIS BE A PRIORITY FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
AND OLD BIDEN USED TO BEFORE
BORDERS, REMEMBER?
[INDISTINCT]
SPEW UNCORRUPTED MEXICO?
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
HE’S NOT TALKING ABOUT THOSE
PROBLEMS.
THE GOAL IS NOT TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS, WHAT HE’S TALKING ABOUT
AND THAT OLD VIDEO, BUT TO OPEN
IT.
IT’S SO BAD THAT STARTED
TOMORROW, BIDEN IS GOING TO USE
TAXPAYER MONEY TO BEGIN
PHYSICALLY RETRIEVING THE 25,000
MIGRANTS NOW LIVING IN MEXICO
WHO WERE DEPORTED THERE BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PENDING
THEIR ASYLUM HEARING.
BUT DON’T WORRY, I’M SURE HE’S
GOING TO GET A TEMPERATURE CHECK
BEFORE THEY BOARD THE BUSES.
AND MAYBE EVEN THEIR FIRST DOSE
OF COVID VACCINE.
I UNDERSTAND SOME MARKETING THAT
TOO.
GRANDMA CAN’T GET IT, BUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS GUN.
THERE MAY BE ROOM FOR COMPROMISE
ON AN IMMIGRATION BILL IF THERE
IS THERE’S ANY SENSE THAT
DEMOCRATS WOULD TAKE ENFORCEMENT
SERIOUSLY.
MAYBE THEY CAN SHOW US FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT THEY WILL
LOGGED ON THE BORDER AND REALLY
ENFORCE IT.
BUT WE KNOW THEY WON’T DO THAT.
IT SAID THIS BILL, LIKE ALL THE
OTHERS THAT CAME BEFORE, WILL GO
DOWN IN FLAMES.
DEMOCRATS WILL TURN OFF MILLIONS
OF ALREADY BELEAGUERED VOTERS
AND THOSE VOTERS WILL GET TO
WONDER WHY THEY EVER VOTED FOR A